the Colorado River that's just west of
Houston is now receding this morning
after cresting near record levels but
forecasters warn that new rains may
trigger more flooding and well Bojorquez
is in LaGrange Texas where the rising
water has forced many out of their homes
as well man well good morning good
morning let me start with this this may
appear to just be standing water right
but this is actually now part of the
Colorado River which is overwhelmed
neighborhoods here in LaGrange you can
see the sign there there are homes down
this road the river crested at about 55
feet that is just two feet shy of the
record set back in the eighteen hundreds
now Lagrange got more than 30 inches of
rain from Harvey and imagine that just
being a wall of water that has to move
down the river and yesterday started to
inundate parts of the town two
neighborhoods here and of businesses and
the main highway highway 71 which cuts
through town is shut down in parts
because of the flooding the only
difference here in this part northwest
of Houston about 90 miles actually is
that the forecast is expecting it to to
cooperate over the next several days
that is the rain is supposed to taper
off giving this possibly a chance to
start to subside but the river is not
expected to be below flood stage here
until at least Friday Nora
Wow incredible pictures there Manny
thank you so much